A space that I love
in anticipation
is the Smith Campus Center.
This is, for me, a
dream that is soon
going to come true with
its completion in the fall.
When I became
president, we started
talking about how to bring
the university together.
And I appointed a task
force on common spaces
to help us think about
the physical foundations
for sharing and
unity and integration
of the university
we could imagine.
And one of the ideas
that soon came out
of that was repurposing
what was then called Holyoke
Center into a campus
center that would not
be part of any
particular school,
but would be a university-wide
space in which people could
bump into each other, share
ideas, find spaces in which
to have meetings for their
organizations and groups,
and embody the unity
that I so strongly felt
would strengthen the university.
And so with a magnificent gift
from Susan and Richard Smith,
we were able to embark on
redesigning the wonderful
[INAUDIBLE] building
located right on Mass Ave
at the center of
the Cambridge Campus
and envision a different way
for the members of the Harvard
and broader communities
to come together.
I think it's going
to be a space that
will change social dynamics,
intellectual dynamics
within the university.
So it's my anticipated favorite
space for the years to come,
though it's still
in my imagination
rather than in actuality.